welcome back to new rock stars news
folks today we got a huge meaty reveal
about Captain Marvel along with the
final Punisher season 2 trailer and a
few TV updates including one sore Game
of Thrones in the mandalorian I'm Erik
Bosse joining me today are Sam basher
and Phillip Molina happy Friday
I like how long it took you to say my
last name my knee-high relish those I'm
having a good time drag out a new facial
they are happy to be here welcome back
great nice little paint brush
particularly in the microphone inhaled
that Aquaman's got a derail this whole
thing over trying to breathe in that
water we're not talking about Aquaman
today because we're talking about
Captain Marvel Sam Jackson dropped a
huge reveal in an inner again chatterbox
he's doing 80 movies a week gang he
can't keep it all straight he let it
flip that Captain Marvel is one of the
few characters in the MCU who can time
travel now this is big news in the
comics Captain Marvel is incredibly
powerful but time travel is not one of
her abilities that we know of so I don't
even know where to start but I have so
many questions so let's look at this
from every possible way we're gonna go
way down the rabbit hole and figure out
what all this means so how will Captain
Marvel slash Carol Danvers is time
travel ability work exactly Doctor
Strange of course has a time stone
ant-man and company have access to
quantum real time vortexes according to
Janet Van Dyne unless she was joking
good joke good joke
so is Captain Marvel going to use her
cat to do this which is enough joke cat
could have the cat is a clerk in right
which it seems like there's a lot of
focus on the cat in the trailers right
there's that moment where Nick Fury's
putting the catches right let's get out
of here for the non nerds can you
describe what a flirt goodness
none of them are watching doing cool
things so they were a blur again is
an alien species that looks a lot like
cats from Earth so they don't even
realize this but in the in the comics
Carol Danvers is cat who's named Julie
in the comics not like goose in the
movie chewy is just her cat and she
loves chewy and then the Guardians the
Galaxy show up and rocket flips out and
he pulls out a gun he's like it wants to
get back I gotta kill this thing they're
like what are you talking about because
that's not a cat that's a fleur kin and
then it ends up being this thing that
its mouth opens up and it's like a John
Carpenter thing with squid monster
coming out and what's interesting in
addition if that's not interesting
enough to you it they contain pocket
dimensions in their mouths that they can
use to like teleport and light speeds
across the galaxy it's just one of these
like crazy reveals that they put in the
comics imagine if we did that if we she
flew into the mouth of a little tiny
house cat yeah
woke up in 1948 well it'd be a big jump
if that's I think the I think there's
more to meet more than meets the eye to
this cat I don't know if it will be a
fleur kin per se but it's going to be a
merkin ELISA Birkin yeah they're gonna
get in a fight with it do you all think
that the cat will claw out Nick Fury's
eye and that's how he loses eye that's
one prevail that's my favorite theory as
well it looks like a cat scratch out of
these cats using the cat that'd be
interesting but it might feel like one
extra just jump personally if in the
others endgame of trying to keep all the
pieces together could be interesting
though for throwing hey I always love
when you throw more sci-fi stuff into my
sign my stuff so yeah I think we we
should really I mean if we're gonna dive
deep list I've deep on exactly what Sam
Jackson said because I'm gonna go on a
limb and guess that he's not referencing
like obscure comics where he's like
actually Captain Marvel is one of the
few you know like I think he's
referencing something that is going to
happen in this movie and that's why we
feel like it's a spoiler but it's
important to too in that context think
okay so what could he mean right does he
I mean he probably doesn't mean leave
she literally can snap her fingers and
appear in a different time but what are
some options we think he could well
perhaps he's just saying she's because
it's been said over and over again that
she is the strongest character the
strongest hero in the MCU in the comics
it kind of changes whose power is
stronger than others at some point Hulk
seems like
strongest character but in the movie
Kevin Feige has said in the movie
universe that Captain Marvel is the
strongest character so maybe he's just
referring to she's the most durable
character so that her body can with span
withstand moving fast in the speed of
light that would require in time-travel
according to Einstein II in physics
right she's capable of time-travel
because she can endure it going through
a wormhole time vortex class okay that
makes sense I mean or it makes enough
sense and I wouldn't be opposed to that
that could be interesting way that
Matthew McConaughey is only human strong
enough to go through a black hole
tesseract and then save Murph and
interstellar right I'm gonna throw out
kind of like a it's it's weird because
it like makes her a little bit of the
MacGuffin of the story like of a
potential end game story be like we must
find Captain Marvel but because she
could potentially absorb energy yeah so
she can absorb energy of any kind then
she could potentially absorb quantum
energy which is the energy that we see
when I'm Scotland try up travels of the
quantum realm we do know that Pym
particles and and whatnot could be
potentially maybe absorbed through that
maybe she could do even like what a man
can do but without the the suit so if
she can do all these things maybe she
can actually channel quantum energy into
kind of snapping her fingers and being
able to time-travel or a little bit kind
of like the flash Sam it's gonna
probably correct me on this but how he
can technically push himself to be able
to travel through time so maybe she can
also technically push herself to be able
to do it to get a good job there's some
there's been some visual analyses of the
color temperature which has led us
astray sometimes in a lot of people have
looked at the color palette of the
quantum realm as we've seen it in
ant-man the wasp in the color palette of
Carol Danvers when she powers up and
goes binary in these trailers it's kind
of a golden glow II rainbow II look to
it and some people are saying there
could be a connection the type of energy
that she uses to power up is she's just
able to reach down to the subatomic
dimension
and harness that kind of energy and use
that and maybe that energy is the same
thing that allows people who are in the
quantum realm to slip you a time board
it's interesting in but it also is
implausible someone might guess like
you're saying the color is the same but
actually if you think about it the MCU
you know hasn't done so much in terms of
music beam like associated with exact
things we've talked about this before
but actually their color schemes are
very much associated with specific
things so think about when Scarlet Witch
uses her powers it's got that very
consistent scarlet hue do it when we
know that someone's under Loki's mind
controlled it's got that it's got Loki's
coloring so the fact that something does
have the same coloring just often is on
purpose
yeah I'm not necessarily saying that
they are the exact same colors yes so
just a fun little like sight thing when
it comes to time travel and her being
able to absorb radiation do you think or
energy because it's just that can just
be pain could be what in comic books
that literally could mean whatever you
want it to mean energy is literally like
so many things in real life - there you
go yeah maybe we could see you're
absorbing not just we're throwing out
the idea of like quantum energy or using
the time vortex or anything like that
maybe she's able to absorb the energy of
the Infinity stones as well there's I
feel like there's because I'm like you
have to function through energy yeah and
they have to exist it basically at that
point they're not gone and they're not
being used by Thanos at this point so
maybe there's a chance that you could
see an older version of one of those
maybe the space stone cuz it's space and
time being able to warp those maybe she
uses that as a way to get to the future
as well or potentially maybe even take
people with her yes and I would like if
that ends up being the case because I
gotta say when I read this quote from
Sam Jackson it kind of bummed me out
because you know as like filmmakers you
want all the magic to come from the same
place in a story so when there's no
double mumbo Jumbo's Blake Snyder's term
for it it's like in the Sam Raimi
spider-man movie the thing that creates
spider-man is not the same kind of magic
that creates Green Goblin it'd be
interesting if it was the same kind of
radioactive spider which I think in the
Ultimate Comics it is kind of the same
basically every bad guy is because of
spider-man yeah kinda yeah sometimes I
did they do that along with TV shows
like when they need to like like
simplify things on agents of shield
right everyone was
dealing with the inhuman Terrigen mists
whatever like they have to make it one
thing is explaining as many things as
possible yes season one a Smallville to
that to it Krypton I gave superpowers
why cuz it did right perfect
so it worried me to see that there's
multi travel such a big messy thing to
introduce into a story so to see like
multiple different ways that it could
come into a story feels like potentially
problematic well I mean that's assuming
that they use multiple different ways
and don't just use like I've found an
old clock it might just be one thing in
the actual thing this is so incredibly
nerdy and I love it it's yeah I feel
good
but we're gonna keep going further us
but let's talk about next how they're
going to use it and Captain Marvel but
in ultimately Avengers in game right
because it's not just setting up for
this movie it's really setting up for
the fight against Thanos it's long been
assumed that time travel will play a
role in the Avengers remaining the
ventures plan to defeat Thanos
and as we said there's been two sources
of time travel possibilities already
introduced the time stone with Doctor
Strange and then ant-man the quantum
realm and now Captain Marvel makes a
third version of time travel aging yes
my question is do we think these are all
gonna work together or do we think that
two of them may just be introduced as
red herrings really there's gonna be one
source of time travel or do you think in
some ways they're going to all the
characters are gonna be using different
forms of time travel to skin the same
kind of think that we have we have our
magic way of going back in time which is
the time zone and I like the way of kind
of like packing it with like Tony Stark
or ant-man since there's like a electro
engineering there's a science side to
that that like you're using the
Microverse the quantum realm whatever
you want to call it as your science
answer to that
time-travel conundrum I like that idea
of using time vortexes and it's kind of
it's a way of doing the classic like
magic versus science because you have
Thanos right visibility and so you could
use their or they're like jerry-rigged
version of that to get around and figure
out how to fix or how to stop Thanos in
different points in time yeah now your
same argument though could
applied to it having to be based on the
time stone because so so one of the
reasons why time travel is is kind of
like frustrating to talk about with
scientists and from a science
perspective is that it can't happen
backward it's something that you can see
and like really dumb it down and make it
sound like that like so dumb that it
doesn't exactly make sense but it kind
of works some people to hear it this way
you can go faster than time to get
further ahead you can't go slower than
that you can't get behind it yeah so but
it has to do with speed right and that's
why you were talking about potentially
going faster than the speed of light
could that potentially make you travel
through time it would make you travel
through time forward right right so the
fact that science doesn't have a great
answer to it means literally whatever
they come up with in the movie if it's
based through science it's gonna be that
mumbo jumbo of like actually time
particles commit and it's like okay this
is made-up science unless they because
of that stick with it being sourced to
magic which is the same thing that
Superman uses one like Superman's powers
are like well though the solar rays make
it so that here in the gravity but then
when they have stuff that's like really
weird like it's that one's magic
otherwise I think what could be possible
is if we assume that captain Marvel's
ability to time travel and Scott Lang's
possible ability to time travel all
comes from the same source the quantum
realm or quantum energy perhaps the
they're gonna take the Infinity stones
off the table maybe what we saw in the
endgame trailer when we had that
close-up of the gauntlet looking fried
maybe the stones no longer work they
anis used it one last time to you know
jetpack out of there after he snapped
half the world out of existence yeah he
just got to Cincinnati yeah maybe it
like just flickered out there's a hub
there though so yeah yeah I think it
might make things too easy and this is
the case in the comics they basically
just steal the Infinity stone from
Thanos and they use it to reverse stuff
I think that's too easy it worked in the
comics and the movie I wanted to be
harder for the characters I don't want
it to make it so that if they can just
get their hands on some of the Infinity
stones rewind the clock they can prevent
this let's make it so that it doesn't
work anymore and then the way they got a
time-travel is their own homegrown
version of time yeah here's here's also
the best K even though I kind of made
the case against that was I gonna go by
saying like science doesn't have an
answer it's still a movie so it probably
will
sciencebase but one reason why i like
that and having to achieve it isn't just
one I agree with Eric that I think it's
gonna be a red herring that you know the
there's the time stone they could always
use the time so I think that's gonna be
like something that's gonna come up in
the movies and they can't use but more
importantly if it's the time stone then
for the rest of the eternity of Marvel
movies there are no stakes because it's
like oh we just get the time stone you
know like unless they bid have to
destroy it which would be a whole other
story line I feel like they'd have to
destroy by the but yes but so it's my
but then like and you end up in this
like Harry Potter situation where with
time Turner is like it's like well then
why don't you go back and fix this and
when you fix this and when he fix this I
like the idea of it being something now
it's so hard to do that for basic humans
which is who were basically dealing with
they can really only do this once right
yeah but time stone or not like
unrelated to the time stone it I don't
like when it's the solution is like all
the funny the time some didn't break or
fall in the ocean or don't you know what
I mean like I don't like when it's that
easy I like it's like no we literally
will die if we try that we can't do it
again
we could do it one time yeah and I think
that also goes for like any kind of
divine intervention you know cuz there's
plenty of cosmic characters were
essentially God in the Marvel Comics and
could easily just drop in and be like
I'll give you this one mission but it's
like well then why are they intervening
now why did they intervene earlier or
they can intervene again it's better to
yeah if they can find one way to
basically like stitch together a weapon
or an attack it's like if we can get in
this one brief window we can fix
everything yeah and here's here's the
simplest way in case like anyone's
having trouble kind of following stakes
why is what I'm talking about a really
easy way to put it is imagine in order
to fix it in order to travel through
time they need to kill five innocent
people yeah and really like I know
that's like a really random thing but
they're not gonna like always be like oh
no I missed the bus
that person that person that person
that'd be like they're not gonna return
to that that's too high up stakes yeah
and I think specifically the idea is
sacrifice if they have to sacrifice
their own lives is the best way to do
that right because then you really can't
do it would you really rather con search
for Spock
kind of thing man I just got an earlier
than the rest of us I heard back on is
one word I'm like what convention season
of
uh-huh yeah for relevant audience but no
I meant that man people think I don't
mean it when I didn't complimenting my
compliments or anyone just noted you run
by it's Wrath of Khan and all right so
how about that that's that's your
prediction right they're gonna be able
to go back but it's gonna cost one
person they're Elias and Star Trek it
does sound like it is gonna be a big
inspiration on it according to Kevin
Feige they're the next generation finale
episode but let's talk about how this
could finally work on work in the movie
Captain Marvel how will it be introduced
this is gonna be like Paris uses
regularly or is it gonna be dropped down
post-credits scene or is it gonna be
something like will she be the type of
time-travel in which the character is
unstuck in time
oh my favorite yeah explain this I have
a fun idea of when it's unschool unstuck
in time what do you mean by that
specifically like is it yeah
what are you thinking cuz in my head a
way that you kind of just get out of
this and can kind of keep Captain Marvel
as its own movie kind of how ant-man the
wasp kind of ends and then when the
credits start it gets to be a trailer
for something else and then but with
this movie I feel like when it comes to
like the scroll threaten everything it
could basically come down to like you
got a bomb you got something with energy
that you need to use to kind of stop
whatever the threat is there you go you
have our absorb it and you never fly out
in space to get it out of the way I own
giant taking out the new classic saying
spoil for that movie but if you have in
in this scenario you could have her
absorb the energy and fly out into space
and this is when you can kind of get
into the science angle of it of her
basically accelerating using that energy
trying to burn off trying not to die
herself but also trying to save whoever
she can from whatever this disaster is
and in that she hits a time she hits
basically the speed of what light and
everything can warp and she's able to
accidentally pop up in the future and
that's how we kind of get her game
that's a real big deus ex machina that
she happened to show up never a big plot
hole to get basically yeah but that is a
way you could do it and also the
snapping could be a big enough fact that
she notices it and she stops yeah to be
clear you're essentially explaining
where she's been this whole time is she
actually it's a very intrigued because
of the events of the movie which we
talked about that before that forces her
to suddenly be gone yeah because like in
all but that could end you don't see
where she ends up by the end of Captain
Marvel before the credits it's basically
she sacrifices herself yeah but
we know as an audience and everyone in
the world knows that she's Marvel will
return ya post-credits scene is her just
like kind of flying through like the
curvature of time you kind of get some
Doctor Strange other-dimensional like
flying through whatever and it ends with
her getting there and I I would lie I
feel like that would be honestly the
best way of her never showing up for any
other huge important like ego
annihilating nine thousand planets and
once kind of scenario because she
literally just wasn't there well to
answer your question about what we mean
by unstuck in time it's uh it's kind of
a different way of looking at time
travel that we've seen in x-men days of
future past and slaughterhouse-five and
in seasons have lost with Desmond your
consciousness your mind is going through
time your body doesn't move it's more of
like your mind can go back to earlier
points in your own individual life
timeline and you're not remembering your
there again you wake up as a younger
person so the way that Wolverine when
Kitty Pryde can kind of zap his brain
she's displacing his consciousness to
when he was a slightly younger version
of him psychos for him he's like you
know ageless too when he was in the 70s
and he can replay certain events of his
life and then he'll pop back in the
future in slaughterhouse-five it's a
fascinating book where he can kind of
jump around at different points in his
own timeline to when he was a boy to
when death happens time is no longer a
linear thing it's just something you're
kind of experiencing all at once
so yeah I mean we have lose what we
experience in anytime you're watching a
movie that or read a book that takes
place out of order you're experiencing
that same thing of like you're unstuck
in time you're jumping around be
experiencing it all together I love that
version of time-travel because it
doesn't have to deal with made-up
science magic orig us like this own
thing that's kind of separate that
results still in the benefits of
time-travel but the reason I think that
they probably won't do it is it doesn't
do what Sam st. did which is explained
where she went right it just allows her
to kind of re experiencing it could that
version could work really well within
just the limits of the movie Captain
Marvel because it's a movie about her
reacts perience seen certain memories
where the memories fake it's kind of
like gonna be memento it sounds like
we're Total Recall where the character
rediscovering certain things about
themselves so she is living a kind of
should existence jumping around at
different points in her timeline going
back in re-experiencing the moment she
got her powers at this crash site that
could be a really cool thing to deal
with and for her to realize how her life
went and why she is the hero that she is
but it doesn't really help you so much
in building the cinematic universe and
how time travel could work an endgame
because it's just one person in their
own individual journey which is why it
kind of works better in books in the
slaughterhouse Drive or certain
character up so it's a lost we just
spent 20 minutes discussing the
potential of time travel in a fictional
universe this has been so nerdy I love
it we're all better off as a result of
this yeah say yeah they're more informed
we're gonna continue talking about this
right we have a we have months and
months before this movie comes out and
answers these questions definitively for
now let's move on to a trivia question
boom
okay so I discovered at the begin of
2019 Travis's well-designed box here a
new true gift for Shane box Travis thank
you again
but Travis earned himself a mug he did
and I believe he got it yeah yeah honey
tweeted us back enjoy every beverage you
drink out of that cheers good friend
so here's yeah got it
clones will be on their way in our
question this week and Back to the
Future Part 2 when Marty McFly time
travels to 2015 what is the name of the
film plane at the hill valley movie
theater okay all of our answers are here
in the box and we'll figure out the
answer of this time travel related
trivia question will be time travel to
the end of the episode and as always the
loser will have to join our club yeah
stellar shirt doc has on you ever looked
at that before oh look at the reference
that's amazing creeped out to be clear
the Train foreshadowed here from Back to
the Future 3 oh yeah they start to
improve great at the same time so
there's a lot of fun they do it like a
cowboy shoot out a video game arcade
yeah heck of a shirt yeah heck of a
movie but let's move on to other stuff
and thank you let's talk about Punisher
because we're seeing it too it's coming
right around the corner GNU
very 18th and CN we have the final real
Big Boy trailer big girl big boy
whatever you'd like and I want to talk
about some of the big moments from it
some of the characters that are being
introduced and some storylines that we
could possibly see so let's start off
right off the bat we get we open with an
amazing fight scene but we also see Jon
Bernthal Punisher protecting a character
named Amy Bendix
now she first appeared in the comics she
is from the comics and I do want to
mention right off the top there are a
lot of characters and storylines in this
season that are original to the show so
yeah that could be kind of cool to see
where these writers get to go when they
have the freedom to but anyways she
first appeared in partial warzone volume
1 issue 24 and it's kind of a similar
storyline that we see in this trailer
we're seeing that she's being protected
by the Punisher because people killed
people that she cared about could be
your family it's change Karyn pages
introduction very similar
father/daughter relationship maybe
between them yeah and we do know that
Punisher did our Frank Castle
specifically had a more personal
relationship with his daughter and at
least that's what you get from season 1
he may not have liked his son very much
for no real reason
would you get a little bit of that but
speaking about guys we don't like we do
get a hint of the one of the villains of
this season we see a man who looks very
proper very pilgrim ask very interesting
because his name in the show is going to
be John pilgrim played by Josh Stewart
who we've seen in minor roles in
interstellar and the Dark Knight Rises
now maybe in deep impact too I think
possibly a movie but I did want to bring
this up because his character as far as
we can tell is from Marvel Comics but no
one's been able to nail down who this
exactly is yet in terms of Punisher lore
there are some theories out there but
when asked about it he's just he was
doing a very good job of keeping this
under wraps and he says you will be able
to figure out by the end of the season
but in terms of who he is and what he
means to Frank is that they're both
similar in the term in terms of
internalized anger and the way his is
going to come out is probably with
religious fury so that's probably gonna
be interesting you know it's insane when
you say religious you know obviously
this isn't exactly traditional like
priests look whatever but it is
reminiscent but specifically reminds me
of the priest from The Exorcist yeah
probably about would do that on purpose
which is very cool I mean I very much
like director John Lightfoot who worked
on this show Nelson worked on Hannibal
so he's he's got a very cool look in the
action this season looks amazing and
that makes me excited for jigsaw
whoo-hoo were gonna see in this looking
more comic accurate played by Ben Barnes
and if we know from Season one we saw
his fall from grace and also his fall
from his pretty face because Punisher
really messed him up but if you guys
want to know a little bit more about him
he first appeared in amazing spider-man
161 before he became a Punisher villain
and he's the only villain that just
keeps coming back because he just can't
be killed and we do kind of get a hint
of what his face looks like in the
comics with when you get to see his
scars usually it's much more messed up
amuck he looks much more like a jigsaw
puzzle puzzle that you push back
together just has like acne scars a
little bit like he he got like he kind
of fell through a window when he was
drunk you know like that bad funny story
he was a foundation that's correct
exactly yeah he just needs a little
touch-up he'll be fine but with this is
the closest that we're probably gonna
get we do see a little bit of his mask
that looks a little messed up this is
kind of a new original creation for the
show but I am interested to see how that
ends up looking but I do want to give a
shout-out to one daredevil act or actor
we do know like you mentioned Karen
Paige was in season was in daredevil she
was in season one of Punisher and she
will be in season two we're also going
to be seeing a detective Mahoney which
is exciting that we're gonna see him at
least one more time very said that
daredevil is gone and so I'm glad we get
to see him one more time seeing him go
up against the Punisher is probably not
going to go well and I do hope he makes
it out of this season I know there isn't
much runway left for these characters
and I don't want to see him go out on
this kind of note also like I mean it
being a character that weirdly we've got
this like fondness for Eve through these
tiny little cameo spread out throughout
Hell's Kitchen hmm but now it is kind of
like Oh a familiar face like that's sad
if you die yeah I really don't want you
go out this way I also hope we get to
see Turk one more time because he's
basically he's always teasin but the
last thing I want to bring up is the
logo we get for Punisher when it finally
shows classic beautiful love it it's
very fun to see can you describe yeah no
but you're getting the classic logo but
in the background you're seeing what
looks like Declassified Russian Intel
files so we're not possibly going to
have sling tied back to Russian villains
for the Punisher possibly Russian
hacking with the religious
fundamentalist villain that we're seeing
this season it's obviously
harkening back to like current fears or
like troubles or woes that Americans
have or the international community but
also when it comes to Russian hacking I
feel like this could be a hint to a
Punisher villain from the comics named
the Russian because why work hard on
that one it's really easy it's called
the Russian he's a bit of a not a super
soldier but he's amped up and he could
be a fun physical threat for the
Punisher but also if we're going with
the Russian hacking angle it could be an
antagonist that we could see for micro
his sidekick from season one who I'm a
big fan of I hope he's in this season as
well cuz he's the only person with a
happy family but let's talk about it are
you guys gonna be watching season two
have you watched season one I'm gonna
ask ya but real quick looking at the at
this - I'm seen I don't know if you know
sis there's like obviously an assault
rifle which goes with the Punisher but
right above it there's a Catholic cross
okay and I feel like that is
specifically from like the kind like a
priest would would have not a it's not a
simple cross I mean you can't see it
it's it looks like the cross of Coronado
from the beginning of Last Crusade and
Indiana Jones like an older piece but I
mean it definitely like you're
everything that you described is kind of
there right the residents the guns I
like a government seal kind of imprint
there too so yeah that was a big part of
season one with government cover-ups and
having to bring that to light and that
gets covered up and so hot possibly
there could be a Russian hacking that
actually brings all of that to light how
they've covered up Punishers workings
the fact that he is alive that is still
covered up and he has been forgiven by
the government so that could be a very
big plot line for you one thing I was
hoping that would happen in the season
was kind of like a little bit of a
playground of whoever they wanted to
bring over from the canceled shows but
I'm hearing that that's probably not
gonna be the case that time yeah they
probably shot it all before I'm so
excited for it's a great show but yeah
yeah I was not gonna have those cameras
probably maybe Alice Eve had an amazing
role as typhoid mary and iron for season
2 and I while that show has his problems
I thought season 2 was better r.i.p but
her character is extremely formidable
and that would be very interesting to
see her go up against someone like Frank
but bad that's probably not going to
happen but Ben Barnes and Jon Bernthal
mystery together is what I'm really
excited for him and I don't know if
we're gonna get a finale for jigsaw in
this season feel like there may have
been a plan to do a season three to kind
of like round out this whole story but
who knows maybe they had a chance to
like edit it and do like a quick pickup
shot of like okay and this is the end
yeah well that'll be coming in a couple
weeks right
January 18th yeah next week next week
yeah a week cool alright so I want to go
back to the super nerdy stuff all right
so I don't know if you guys know that I
heard about this with the ant-man the
wasp director Peyton Reed he was at a
Q&A recently and he confirmed something
that we brought up in in a previous
video or he like kind of confirmed that
he was coy like they all are they'd like
it like they do those like little tiny
hints that are basically confirmations
uh-huh so he was talking about Janet Van
Dyne he was talking about the quantum
realm and he included this little nugget
about this image if you can't see it
it's when we're going through the
quantum realm if you freeze frame on
your home blu-ray or digital streaming
you'll see very quickly what looks like
a little city a little civilization
nugget and pay my age straight up said
yeah that does look like people live
there so he's like yeah but he's
basically confirming for us that there
could be essentially if the quantum
realm is the equipment of microburst
potentially a micro world here would
make a lot of sense for how Janet Van
Dyne was around for you know 30 years in
the in the we a lot of us have thought
like was she floating that whole time is
wandering around hunting totally yeah
she was she was eating tardigrades and
but she was also potentially a member of
this community it would make a lot of
sense for why she has we talked about
this before she's wearing more when they
find her at the end with her like mask
and whatnot
then she went in with right so it's like
where did she find new materials yeah so
she potentially you know has joined the
society she's also to imply that she's
gone through some sort of evolution
right so if she has initially just been
in her suit but over time has able to do
whatever it is that these people are
able to do to survive
maybe that's the kind of evolution that
she's not learned so it's just kind of
big news for us because again the same
thing that we were talking about earlier
if this is you know definitely a
civilization also I'm gonna remind
everybody that crazy theory that I
remember as they're passing through the
same moment there's a lot of blinking
orange lights and it's theoretically
around the time that the snap could have
happened so a lot of people think that
could be the souls of the people orange
being the color of the soul stone the
souls of everyone that got snapped away
just being shifted somehow to the
quantum break you see an influx of
quantum healing particles the mome and
the snap happens right people are
thinking could that be right Tinkerbell
sparks dead people but he's probably not
bringing up yeah there could be people
there and then we're never gonna see
that again so that's kind of I think
decent-sized news yeah this is this is a
fascinating - my favorite thing for me
I'm in the Mosman if you're looking for
it and you're rewatch is at home it's
precisely the moment where items well
this is before the press it's right when
he and Janet Van Dyne zoom out of this
area and there's just like panning shot
and then the kind of linger a little bit
so we were wondering maybe he
intentionally lingered but lingers
always that sounds like the best plot
for an ant-man 3 like honestly like
don't do more like high jinks or high so
go spend the whole time there like maybe
there you have loot bring Lewis with you
because that'd be fun I like that's
bring my favorite parts of those movies
yeah and yeah it's maybe it's an escape
from that's the heist part of it is you
trying to get out of there and figure
out what was Janet doing that entire
time and maybe like there's a stage
somebody chooses to stay down there for
some reason like to do science or maybe
that's how Hanks him like chooses to
like go out in this world is that he
stays down there all of his work has led
to this and that's really I feel like
that'd be a very good ant-man to repot
but for sure yeah the Marvel comics have
like precedent of societies and
civilizations that exist on this in them
they call it Mike the Microverse in the
comics or there's like different areas
that have different names there's like
micro world there's subatomic ax there's
a good name planets tiny different IDs
there's yeah and there are moments where
the thing from the Fantastic Four it
kind of like in Hulk Hulk and Thor
Ragnarok decides to stay down there
because it's kind of this like celebrity
gladiator fighter and one of these
worlds and Scott Lang has to go down
there and be like dude what are you
doing come on let's go I want to stay
here so there are reasons people would
want to stay down there
oh the talk the T okay there's like the
lizards of talk is or one of those
civilizations of course I don't think
any of they're all pretty goofy I don't
think any of them are ones that I'm like
dying to see on the big screen but
what's coolest about this is there's
precedence like the Microverse of Rick
and Morty of an entire civilization
exacting on a tiny scale right you know
it's funny is I just just real quick
just imagine the people you can do this
at home to imagine the people that live
in the Microverse here just think of
them in your head for a second I hear
them talk real quick do they have high
voices of course comically low voices
[Laughter]
zoom in there they're probably gonna
seem normal-sized by scale but for some
reason my head they're all like
munchkins yeah but I think that is a
huge question like how was she able to
survive for that long she looks like
kind of like Katniss Everdeen bit of a
hunter left on her own yeah it's
frustrating no one like a character has
all this information they don't share it
within the first 30 minutes of like
being back should be oh my god there was
a whole civilization down there yeah you
gotta meet them I know we had to go get
the special medicine for goat yeah like
could we go down to the city for we
don't have the tech to go to space can
we go to the who am i saving someone
named ghost someone who's trying to
murder you yeah I have a new husband
that I left behind Empress of this it'll
be easy just make yourself just a tiny
bit taller than everybody and works in
our society to you think about this and
the comments below we'll continue
talking about this that makes me excited
endgame will answer some questions there
but what else cuz in other news we've
been hearing them the Mandalorians
season will include eight 45-minute long
episodes yes right really happened he's
been saying for years can we just make
that the new normal yeah but also HBO
announced that it will soon announce the
Game of Thrones period date on Sunday so
yeah they announced see the tweet it's
it's just a text message the HBO Twitter
account is really funny you guys should
follow it it's a text message between
the social media coordinator of HBO and
like his boss and he's like when does
the premiere day to get announced and
he's like it is just a text conversation
just watch true detective we're like
doing it there that was their
announcement was a screenshot of this
that's amazing I do follow them I was a
big fan of their Sopranos little mean
yeah it was amazing but also the vision
and Scarlet Witch Disney Plus show has
hired a writer we have Jack Schaeffer on
board that's amazing she wrote the
Captain Marvel movie Black Widow as well
the upcoming one and that super long
frozen short film that everyone got mad
about Coco I was lucky enough to miss
that one but I'm a fan our aya knows an
adventure and you know I get I'd love
Coco to and I didn't realize that this
show was happening I was this a Scarlet
Witch show that was separate from the
Loki series they were originally were
gonna be in a show together and then
they decided they're gonna do a separate
series they were talking about two
separate series who said right off the
bat it's this that's now it could be
vision in skirt I don't know vision was
gonna be he was always gonna be part of
the Scarlet Witch I believe they they
said an Avenger and we're like with
vision like yeah I still like the
version where's vision after the stone
has been removed where Eric said he just
has like a headache
like what you're applying is that he's a
lot dumber now yeah
don't feel good I went outside through
the door but I'm in a closet now wow
what kind of hijinks shift through the
door I don't know I do
did you run into it vision no this and
more this is trademarked by the way you
can't take the story ideas Marvel ticket
yeah eight episodes you guys tweeted
some stuff and yeah what's happening now
offensive vision I avoided certain vocal
tones to mate it okay
you didn't say die at the beginning
someone calls a defense all right time
to get offended let's do a lightning
round real quick boom Eric at a swifty
13 these are lightning round closer to
area you guys you tweeted Eric how dare
you I was trapped in the closet
well oh that makes sense and I didn't
mean for it to we'll Quicksilver return
after the snap is undone oh oh I hope so
right of all the characters who have
kind of faded at the picture yes I hope
so yes confirmed at Star Wars fans is
for sam 2187 same talking over there
Blade Runner come on who would win the
Avengers or ready quick lightning round
Justice League Avengers just like a
superpower there's this league yeah
alright Philip at a hungry tree who is
your favorite voice actor ooh Kevin
Conroy probably I mean it's if that
voice is just he is Batman Forever and I
get over yeah that's right Kilmer is my
favorite voice actor
I think that anytime I hear another
Batman it's just like an impostor
that's that Eric at sea might spin move
what's boss's bench press PR a personal
record via I don't do bench press I do
it I do other work out other than bench
pressing but here's what I can do I did
bench press what oppa do is I'll do
individual dumbbells and I can do two at
the same time up to 45 so 90 but I could
probably do more I just I don't like
using the bar cuz I work out alone and I
don't have a spot or anything oh well
you're taking applications let somebody
work out I'm there empress lets you
Philip Adam P Farnsworth do you think
that Scott Lang in the end game trailer
could be a scroll no at Bruce Game Freak
do you think that our DJ will return to
the MCU I'll maybe take a lesser role
with the Avengers
yes that was easy of course yes he likes
money yeah great I also his life was
ruined before this and every got better
after Eric at poop this monster what's
your favorite song of 2018 this is
America great Eric that was you Sam at
mock day when Beast Boy is sick does he
go to the doctor or the vet when the
question is the joke and then you have
nothing you can say that's gonna be
funny or maybe this is that mark day I'm
not sure they started to get weird what
do you guys think of the us trailer so
yeah okay that was my favorite thing
about it is that we have seen songs used
and like Sloan down like oh now that
song is either emotional or creepy but
songs that are actually relevant to my
childhood because I grew up so weird
like that hit me to my core and also the
crying oh so good he's gonna be the next
great horror King I think so uh Sam at B
heart 16-4 at Sam basher best show in
the Michael Schur universe the servers
you mistress so we got Parks and Rec off
of the office he's punching himself if
you can't see him he's so red Sam it's
like Hellboy Sam wake up Sam wake up it
was just a dream you office the office
yeah good place is right behind it it's
ours Parks and Rec I've never watched
Brooklyn nine-nine Cesar what was boring
99 oh it's so good the office is the
number one show I like still for a
reason flight I seven will I save myself
heartbreak by joining hashtag team night
king for season eight of Game of Thrones
oh yeah you will sit that guy I hope he
decimates gonna win okay he's earned it
send those to us and we'll feature them
in round and now comes the time for a
15-second shout-out where each of us is
15 seconds to shout out plug or ramble
about anything we want and let let's try
to keep it under 15 seconds I never do
but I'm gonna put personal 15 I heard 50
every time 15 we have someone counting
off-screen I don't write and who's ready
go I mean I'm a gold watch Young Justice
on DC Universe friend of the show
Whitney Moore has a character on oh my
god it was amazing to see her on it and
if you see her her character name has
the same first name as her so that's
incredible and it's the reason to buy
the DC Universe app oh great well done
yeah do you have one yep go in great so
we act like we know everything about
movies and we should work in the
industry and you guys are like oh you
guys have no idea what you're talking
about the guy that used to run new rock
stars has a new TV show called Informer
so the New York Times said it's amazing
BBC it's on Amazon I'm not actually
carrying another 15 seconds that's like
the guy that used to work - yeah that's
like Brandis has a TV show that is like
blowing up and people are saying it's
gonna be like like this huge new show
informer check it out on Amazon that's
huge is good friends of ours Rory Haines
we're very impressive
right now we hoped funny for our year
but he went over the 15 seconds I would
say the oh boy I'm time I had in my head
I think you should all go well magnet
poetry show a marvelous mr. Mays Ilana's
on prime I just it's awesome it's great
it's great I don't know a lot of our
viewers think about that kind of show
it's awesome it's it's great it's super
fun if you're like into comedy history
it's it's from like it's an interesting
period
Sam's mad about it yeah there were no
stakes there were nothing went wrong
let's do it the our trivia question that
we asked earlier our loser will have to
join the gif of shame oh [ __ ] to remind
ourselves of the question that we asked
in Back to the Future Part we're gonna
be working on doing audio versions of
this so just throw it out there for a
gift of shame if you want to see this
horrible thing that we're made to do
just follow us on social media add new
rock stars on Twitter and you'll see
this gif of shame and you can use it for
whatever purposes you would literally
whatever purposes you have yes are a
question in Back to the Future Part 2
with Marty McFly time travels to 2015
what is the name of the film a plane on
the hill valley movie theater so what do
we each say first up Eric said jaws 9
and in quotes the shark still looks fake
I know Marty says the shark still looks
fake cuz that's a joke FEMA says jaws 5
ah and sam says jaws 30 or James Bond 12
I think I best out what up I think I
messed up how big James Bob movies were
out James 1:12 might have already
happened every airing the
correct answer is jaws 1919 closest I
was going over think that's the rules of
Jeopardy almost Doubleday
yeah yeah then I would win yeah I think
Sam's a James Bond I think there's
actually another movie I had James Bond
but it's a J it's another job it's not
jaws there's another movie that's airing
that has like a 19 or something
jaws it might be charged was it like the
Miami Dolphins beat the Cubs in the
World Series or something like what it
was a Marlin to beat the Cubs but what
was weird about it is they were the
Florida Marlins at the time of the movie
and but later they did become the Miami
Marlins by the time Back to the Future
came out so that happened but they're in
the same league so they can't play in
the World Series whoa save yourself
there yeah I definitely could yeah all
right so what's this gif of shame no I
didn't write James Bond on my camera for
I'm not furthest yeah and then I gained
a lot of points by not writing James
Bond I was away bit away shame the math
is taking too long
[Laughter]
what alright so joining the gift of
shame Wow it's gonna draw a thing from
our bin and he's gonna to do this action
and look all goofy on camera and
hopefully it'll be turned into an
animated gif put on our social media so
what'd you drop didn't like that no that
one said Sam specifically alright you
know Clockwork Orange
go on absorb subliminal brainwashing
okay so Sam can I get a get an assist in
the chair I can't
look at it it's so beautiful it's oh my
gosh stuff of nightmares
well I'm gonna get through this quickly
oh yeah we should I need every eye drop
it's so expensive thank you for watching
this week's episode of new rock stars
news I want to thank our host Sam
bachelor at Sam bachelor Villa Molina at
fimo and Eric bot sets me a TA vas
comment down below
tweet us that new rock stars like this
video share it around subscribe so deep
dives in all the stuff you love philip
has your ultraviolence been desensitized
yet or do you still want to do bad
things
next week everyone thanks for watching
bye bye